-Horatio posted
this online recently.
This was a -- This is a famous
"SNL" party, to this day.
-Tablegate.
-This is Tablegate.
This is me, you...
-Yeah, I look sober there.
-...Horatio.
This is Mike Shoemaker.
[ Laughter ]
And this is --
This was a party that was
the last Thursday of
the last episode of the season.
And we went up into our --
And this is the writer's room.
-This is the 17th floor.
-17th floor at "SNL."
-Of the building.
-And this is, like,
when it's normal,
'cause the table's fine.
It's called Tablegate --
-For a reason.
-We drank -- We started just
throwing alcohol on the table.
-Yeah. Well, what happened was,
it was a punch bowl.
It was very...civil.
-Yeah.
Very civil.
-And just had punch bowl drinks.
But now and then, people
spilled a little on the table.
And then -- just,
by the end of the night,
people were just --
it got very --
there was just drinks
all over the table.
And I thought it'd be funny
if I ran from the hallway
and dove on the table
like a Slip 'N Slide...
-Yeah.
-...and slide across the table.
And I did it.
-Yeah.
On all this alcohol,
I just dove through it and slid.
And then,
it became funny and fun.
everyone wanted to do it.
Then we all did it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And I remember a friend of ours
Andrew Steele
had to stand at this window.
'Cause people would come,
like, sliding this way.
[ Laughter ]
-And catch -- catch --
-Yeah.
He would literally catch people.
-Or else you'd fly out
a 17th-floor window.
[ Laughter ]
Somebody's working at their
desk, like, "Jimmy Fallon?"
-"Hey, what's up, man?"
I mean, what were we thinking?
-It was crazy.
We actually got in
a lot of trouble
because we broke the table.
And it was -- It was
my first year on the show,
and I had really thought,
"I think you can get fired
for breaking furniture."
[ Laughter ]
-I remember that we were
so embarrassed the next day.
And we were like --
because it was really insane.
There were just cups everywhere.
And I remember there was a --
[ Laughs ]
Somebody got mad at us
and yelled at us,
and they said,
"Really classy, guys."
[ Laughter ]
"Really classy move."
And you know
what was the extra touch?
It was the towel full of vomit
in front of
Carson Daly's office.
[ Laughter ]
I was like,
"That wasn't me, man."
-Yeah.
-"I don't know who did that."
-I do think that's classy.
The other thing that's
embarrassing is when you're --
And it was literally
my first year on the show,
and we used to get free stuff,
and I want to point out --
I don't know if you remember
the 2002 Winter Olympic berets
from Salt Lake City.
[ Laughter ]
Literally wearing a free --
-That's some good style.
-That's a good, good style.
-Oh, gosh.
-Like you mentioned,
both have two kids.
-Yeah.
-You got two girls.
-I got two boys.
What made you write a book
about making a first child --
a first word dada.
-What was your baby's
first words?
Do you remember?
-I think it was "mama."
-Of course it was.
Yeah, it is.
It just is.
And I know it's an unwritten
kind of contest
that husbands have with wives.
And you go, "No, that's great.
It could be any word."
But I really wanted her
to say "dada" first.
And so I was just
trying to trick her.
Anything I would give her --
I mean, I was --
I would give her a bottle
and go, "Do you want dada?
Do you want a dada?"
[ Laughter ]
I don't care
if the baby is stupid,
I just want,
for the history books --
That's up to someone else
to fix my baby.
I just wanted,
for the history books,
that first word was "dada."
So I put the book out,
and it was funny, as a joke.
And then,
people started actually
really reading it with the kids.
And then, kids started reading
it back to their parents,
and it became a cool thing.
And so they said,
"You should make mama."
And I was like -- And
it's clearly written by me
'cause there's only like
10 words in the book.
It's like,
"Mama, quack, mama, moo."
[ Laughter ]
It's not ghost written.
-Where do you get your ideas?!
-Oh, just over a text!
[ Laughter ]
So I put out "Mama,"
and I figured,
since women
are smarter than men,
mamas, they don't care.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes.
-'Cause they are.
-That is correct.
-They don't care about
if the baby says "mama or dada"
in the sequel.
And it's called
"Everything is Mama."
In that one,
the mama's trying to teach kids
that there are other words.
-Oh, I see.
-So it's like "Balloon," things
like noodles, stuff like that.
And then the baby just keeps
saying, "Mama, Mama, Mama."
So, anyways, yeah.
I'm writing a lot of books.
-That's fantastic.
-I'm an author now.
-Oh, that's great.
Well, we love
having authors on the show.
-Hey, I just want to say, dude,
I watch you every night,
and I watched you
since you began.
You're doing such a great job
on the show.
And everyone here really --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Job well done, dude.
-I really appreciate it.
Thank you for handing it over.
It's an honor to do it.
Give it up for Jimmy Fallon,
everybody!
"The Tonight Show"!